monsieur el mili bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france à leur
nouveau président tebboune veut donc
vraiment rompre avec le passé on le
disait avec l'ère bouteflika une
révision de la constitution
est-ce que cela vraiment permettra de
tourner la page
oui définitivement
souvenons nous il y a un an au même
moment ont préparé les îles sont
présidentielle le pays était en crise la
situation constitutionnelle était as
they médoc l'élection présidentielle a
permis de résoudre la crise du régime
aujourd'hui l'élection le lot de
référendum pour la constitution permet
de résoudre la crise politique
et comme ce qu'on appelle le kerax bas
mot pour mot aux masques véritable
révolution et la date choisie c'est le
1er novembre est la date du
déclenchement de la révolution
algérienne
donc c'est pour bien marquer c'est une
façon de dire je vous ai compris
on choisit son lad le texte rappelle a
été adopté en conseil des ministres le 6
septembre dernier aujourd'hui donc ça
sera devant le parlement
le parlement at il des
des chances de le rejeter ou vous pensez
que le texte va vraiment passé
aujourd'hui
non pas du tout le faire passer devant
le parlement c'est un formalisme et je
ne comprends pas pourquoi parce que le
parlement aujourd'hui est entachée par
des scandales
il ya un très grand nombre de députés
qui avaient acheté leur siège pour être
élu donc mais mais on a on est dans un
format livre pourquoi pas mais il sera
pas rejeter
elle est comme tout qui quand ce sera le
taux de participation
parce que pour moi je vois ce référendum
ont eu comme étant une élection de
confirmation et je vois pas des députés
qui sent qu'ils ont une mauvaise image
tellement qu'on puisse dire rejeté un
projet pour entrer dans une nouvelle ère
l'algérie a été chamboulée à par ce
mouvement
irak un mouvement de contestation est ce
que justement c'était une des
revendications de cette jeunesse cette
révision de la constitution est ce que
c'est une avancée majeure aujourd'hui en
algérie
non le le vrai rat qui a commencé
c'était s'élever contre le cinquième
mandat et à la classe à gagner ensuite
cette fabuleuse dynamique ne s'est pas
arrêté et il y à plus d'unité on voit un
tel mouvement qui n'a pas fait émerger
de leader pourquoi pas mais ce qui
emporte plus interpellant il n'y a pas
de programme
maintenant on a une constitution dans
les grandes lignes les pouvoirs sans
équilibrer le régime restera
présidentielle parce que l'algérie ne
veut pas tomber dans le scénario
tunisien où on voulait pas qu'une
personne est le et tous les pouvoirs le
résultat c'est que plus personne ne
décide le régime sera présidentielle
mais les députés auront leur mot à dire
c'est ça maintenant ce qui reste parce
que la constitution même bien écrite ne
sera qu'un texte
et après il faudrait que la politique
algérienne apprennent à fabriquer des
députés qui votent des lois et surtout
que ces lois là soient appliquées vous
l'avez dit le texte va passer en
référendum populaire le 1er novembre 1
qui marque anniversaire du début de la
guerre d'indépendance de l'algérie
les algériens vont répondre présents
à votre avis lors de ce référendum bon
il y aura toujours
parce que un texte de la référendum de
la constitution
c'est un texte qui n'est pas facile à
lire
ce n'est pas pour le chou comme le choix
d'un président ont connu pour en est
contre là il y aura un taux d'abstention
qui est propre à tous les référendums
cependant les gens qui vont voter vont
voter oui je ne vois pas une
mobilisation pour le non
de la pâte sans et l'abstentionnisme est
récurrent dans toutes les sociétés
on sait pas à quel taux sera élevé cette
non participation mais pour le moment je
n'ai pas entendu de véritables appels au
boycott bien sûr il ya toujours des gens
pour se différencier qui disent on ne
vote pas parce que il privilégie un
scénario d'une constituante et la
constituante
c'est un processus qui est pro naufrage
je suis toujours l'exemple de la tunisie
ils ont mis deux ans et demi pour avoir
une constitution et pendant deux ans et
demi il n'y a pas eu d'économie et
maintenant la situation encore plus
grave
il ya eu cette pandémie et a fait
arrêter toute la planète et d'algérie ne
pas se permettre de rentrer dans un
processus au naufrage merci vous prend
en tout cas naoufel brahimi les ennemis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur en
histoire et spécialiste des relations
franco à jacques